there's a new game of Thrones Season 7
promo out now called long walk let's
have a quick look
so the promo focuses on three main
characters Jon Snow Daenerys Targaryen
and Cersei Lannister who each walk and
take their place at their respective
seats of power Jon as king in the north
in Winterfell Cersei is Queen of
Westeros on the Iron Throne and Dany at
her seat on the island of Dragonstone
from there she hopes to invade and
conquer Westeros Dragonstone has a lot
of history and symbolism for Dany and
her family the Targaryen x' Dany was
born at Dragonstone and centuries before
her great-great-great great-great-great
great-great-great-great
great-grandfather Aegon the conquerer
left from Dragonstone to take Westeros
and establish the Targaryen dynasty go
watch that video so Danny is walking in
the footsteps of her ancient ancestor
it's by the Rite of Aegon's conquest
that Dany means to claim her crown the
Cersei might have something to say about
that Cersei has walked two she's been
shamed and beaten down for her crimes
but it seems to have only made her
angrier crueler more dangerous after the
deaths of her three children so she has
nothing to lose but her throne so she
won't easily let it go
Jon Snow is also walking which is
impressive given the state he was in
last season Jon has experienced death
felt the cold and he knows about the
real threat to Westeros he'll be using
his power as king in the north to try to
convince everyone to stop with the
political squabbling and to focus on the
true enemy
because when the candles go out and the
eyes all closed a blue eye opens and I
of the White Walkers this particular eye
looks like it belongs to a giant look at
the big nose so this might be one one
the giant who died at the Battle of the
bastards looks like he's been raised as
a zombie so fight for the wine Walkers
the books all sorts of creatures join
the army of the dead there's a zombie
bear zombie birds talk of dead things in
the water it seems that anything that
can die can become an undead servant of
the walkers some fans speculate we could
see a zombie dragon George Mardon did
write a book called the ice dragon after
all the point is the walkers are clearly
set up as the main threat to Westeros
this next season so this promo the long
walk evokes not only where our
characters are going but also where
they've been
John Danny and Cersei have each come a
long way since season 1 Jon Snow was a
know-nothing naive baby-faced bastard
boy not so long ago but soon became a
battle-hardened leader of the Nights
Watch he was a corpse for a bit but is
now the king of all the north Danny was
the political pawn of a crazy brother
Viserys but became the dragon queen of
murine she was for a while a Dothraki
captive but is now a powerful Conqueror
Cersei started as a cruel capricious
incest queen and now she's well she's
about the same really but she certainly
is angrier and is now the queen of
Westeros so these three have all walked
a long way they've all been brought low
but are now more experienced mature and
powerful than ever before this is like
that point in a video game where your
characters fully leveled up maxed out
and ready to face the final boss in this
case White Walkers and winter and the
night that never ends thanks for
watching make sure to subscribe and to
turn on post notifications so you don't
miss a video
just press that Bell button and thanks
to the patrons including sir Ron pinata
Cole Handel Lane Debbie Lew Molly
manning Tony enou D and nink Cheers
you